it will actually be the third time
this is a no
no no this is not the third time this is
not yet
that will be only the second time i
think
if he plays rock c5 it will be twice
so he played on c5 is he panko looking
at his car [ __ ] as well
bishop b7 played
and now if he plays rugby fights is the
third time
he's looking at him
yeah i think marcus was kind of offering
a draw yeah but they cannot follow any
any point yeah
he agrees but he seems to think it's
third time
okay some a mess here but zebus just
repeating
they are not allowed to offer draw
whatsoever i don't know i don't know
what's all
i i don't think there's any hole i i i
so terrorists would know probably
say it's a 40 moves rule no i think in
general
draw offer should be abolished no
that's what do you think is that your
co-second blood blood we're
talking yeah i know you've forgotten
you you've got about your friend leo now
yeah
not no i have fully okay
i mean i'm not in charge it seems no
yeah i think one time i made a quick
draw i made a quick draw
and i felt really ashamed later
i met this queen in 626 berlin
okay i was black i was very happy i
could go to the beach
[Laughter]
it was the best day of the tournament
that's for sure i could make